good morning believe nation today's
messages think outside the box over you
Peyton Manning I wake up PVE go don't
let expertise silence you work to find
new solutions to old problems think
outside the parameters that restrict
other people's thoughts just because
you're a novice on the job just because
you haven't faced the same challenges
just because you haven't climbed the
same cliffs does it mean that you can't
contribute to solutions in very
significant ways when you're chided for
your naïveté and you will be rely on
your critics that an amateur built the
ark experts built the titanic think
outside the parameters that restrict
other people's thinking I really love
that quote from Peyton and I think for
you to have success in any field you are
going to have to do it your way if you
want to be a singer you can't do it like
Madonna like Britney like the Beatles
like Elton John whoever you can't be
them you can only be yourself and have
the courage to model success to find
what has worked for different people but
then you need to tweak it so that it
fits for you there is no one path for
you as a creative individual because you
have never lived before this is the
first life that you are living so there
is no exact blueprint you still have to
figure it out even if you're pulling
things from different people and that's
a scary part because the temptation is
to go and follow exactly what somebody
else has done follow the exact plan that
they did but that's not how you're going
to achieve success because you will only
be a clone of somebody else instead of
unleashing your true art your true
creativity to create something that can
be meaningful and lasting and
world-changing I think it's especially
hard because it's never been done before
and so instead of only following
somebody else's path you have to go out
and create your own I look at my own
YouTube channel and when I was in your
your days of my channel i made this
video that i was really proud of that i
really enjoyed and I said that somebody
was in the movie industry and he hated
because the movie was six minutes long
and he said no video should be six
minutes long on YouTube and he said the
most popular YouTube videos are 30
seconds or a minute or whatever it was
and the fact that yours is six minutes
long means that it's going to be a
failure and how sad would it have been
for me to listen this guy who who knows
what he's talking about who's who has
the experience in the industry who has
all the stats and data to back him up
how sad would have been for me to listen
to him and say no to shrink down to a
lesser version of myself was something
that I loved and was really passionate
about but not do it because this guy
who's an expert said I shouldn't do it
how many times do you listen to the
people around you who have no idea what
they're talking about or we didn't they
did they're in the industry they can't
give you the right direction that you
need for your life and that was the
birth of the little man that guy that
individual became little man for me as a
as you know a human embodiment of what
little man is and now has become a
symbol for anybody who's hating on your
idea who tries to trash it tries to
bring you down that video spoke to me I
loved it and so I had the courage to put
it up even though the people around me
said not to and by the way that video
was the first video having my channel to
hit 1 million views and so you're gonna
have people around you who tell you that
it can't be done that it's not smart
they shouldn't do it and that doesn't
always mean that it's going to work out
to I've tried a lot of stuff that people
said was stupid that that didn't work
out at all but just the fact that
somebody is telling you that doesn't
work shouldn't be the be-all and end-all
at the end of the day you need to listen
here you got to listen to your heart you
got to listen to what makes you come
alive and least knowing if I did not
post that video I would live with regret
for the rest of my life that I didn't
post it or that I cut it down with that
I made it something that I wasn't truly
proud of or at least I would know to
have the certainty that it didn't work
out or the good fortune that it did work
out and so stop only listen to those
people around you take their advice for
what it is advice but at the end of the
day
you have to make a decision on what's
best for your life because you got one
chance to live it so do a good job so
the question day today is I'm curious
what are you doing that is outside the
box of the norm for your industry super
curious to find out leave in the
comments below and I will join the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Michael Henry Michael thank
you so much for buying my book really
means a lot to me those you guys
watching you want a chance that a shadow
in the future video make sure to pick up
a copy of the book and email in your
receipt so we can keep track thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot events vesa away this race okie
beagle